hi I'm Raven Symone and this is how I
got better I was born in Atlanta Georgia
my mother and father met in Atlanta they
had me at a young age they put me into
modeling my mother's favorite show was
The Cosby Show
one day I guess I saw the look on my
mom's face and I said hey I can do what
Rudy can do they packed up everything
and they sold everything they had they
put me in the back of their car and we
drove to New York I auditioned and I got
the part now I love being on television
sets from age three till age thirty I'm
more comfortable there I know what lines
I'm supposed to say somebody else picks
my clothes for me I have makeup done I
have hair done and you create a family
with these people that sometimes are
closer to you than your own family it's
not very healthy later in life for me my
likeness whether you see it in an
interview whether you see it on print
whether you see it however you see it at
that time had 15 people dictating what I
should and should not look like if I did
whatever I want I'm not going to sell
because it doesn't go with the brand I
was branded at such a young age and then
you wonder why all these child stars
have these issues you were not allowing
them to grow up as human beings you were
stifling them at the youngest and most
important development age of their time
and then you expect them to be normal
later in my head I have three different
brains at that age you had to
compartmentalize when you're in the
public eye you have to I dare you to
know all of your school and go to class
and do a TV show and do the red carpet
and not talk back because you're still a
kid so there's a little bit of a
disconnect for me in that
area my awareness of my sexuality was
prevalent to me at 12 but there was some
things younger in like the 10 single
digits I had friends that I experimented
but never went far because I knew that
this can't be talked about I kind of
like pushed myself to open myself up to
look for boys in a more than just you
know I had way I look back now I'm gonna
like whoa you liked girls you liked him
I didn't want to tell my parents because
I didn't I knew I couldn't say it out
loud because oh my god literally little
Olivia's gay this is crazy I had the
number one show on Disney I had multiple
albums but I've been on tour with NSYNC
people had bucket lists my bucket list
was finished at 18 I didn't want to deal
with that I didn't want to deal with it
and I didn't care what was going on I
remember when Ellen came out and I
remember rumors surrounding other people
but when that happened there were no
good conversations coming out of it it
was always negative so if you don't see
other people going through it in a
positive way why would you say anything
there was nothing that would have made
me want to deal with my own issue at
that time nothing even if I got sick I
probably would have been like I'm taking
this to the grave but that eats at your
soul that eats at your soul
period
I never thought I would ever come out
I never thought I would come out because
my personal life didn't matter it was
only what was supposed to be sold as you
know the Raven Symone print so it was
something that I always thought in my
head I'll always have a friend I'll have
a husband I'll have a friend on the side
so I can be happy so I can have both you
know taken care of I get this you get
the beard you go to whatever that didn't
last I don't care anymore because I fell
in love and I was kind of over the
industry I wanted to retire I said well
if I'm not gonna be in the industry then
I can come out so I did that went to
college I felt good and I had support
there beyond belief and that was the
first time where I felt like I didn't
have to have a beard I didn't have to
have a man standing by me because I'm in
love with a girl and I had a call with
my mom and she was like I don't know
what's going on I know this is a phase
and like yeah mom it's a phase and I'm
gonna let you have that sentence because
I didn't tell you about it I hid it from
you for so long so I'll let you go
through the natural progression of what
a parent thinks when your child comes
out it's a phase they'll get over it
okay I'll let you have it she's still
working with it and I told my dad he was
like I had a feeling I'm like yeah I had
like every pair of Jordans ever of
course not that that means anything but
I mean hello I felt lighter I felt like
I could go out and not have to put on 17
different hats to be myself
so I fell in love
when I realized that just living my
truth of what I am there's one less
person to fight me in my own head I can
get to the problem a little bit more but
art is my passion I can sit in my art
room for hours and not hear one voice
it's kind of like sanctuary for me that
took away even the fight of my sexuality
in my head it's the first time I
actually felt free is with my my
physical art so now when I deal with an
issue with my weight or with a friend or
a family member or something in the
industry it's not that hard as of right
now if I had to speak to someone that
was going through a problem in their
life that feels too large to even deal
with the good news is it will pass
you'll get bumps and bruises but if you
stick through it people forget people
forget and time goes on and hopefully
you learn from it don't stress learn how
to deal with it now that you're young
openness is most important because it
doesn't matter what you see me as and
you label me it's what I label myself
it's funny because when I came out I was
like oh my god I'm gonna die I thought I
was gonna die because when you hold on a
secret for so long like it just keeps
building and building and building and
one day the top is gonna explode over
first of all I thought I lost all my
talent cuz I thought that my secret game
is inside of me was the reason I was so
amazing but it wasn't um it was just
making my tears a lot bigger